hi there this is my message to
Millennials about how to change the
world and I would say how to change the
world properly of course the question
then is well exactly what do you mean by
properly and of course that's the
fundamental issue so I'm going to walk
through that little bit so I'm gonna and
I've also got an offer to make to any
Millennials that are willing to watch
this so this was triggered in part by
something I read recently by Jonathan
hate and Jonathan Haidt is the professor
of ethical leadership at the NYU Stern
School of Business and he's been a very
astute commentator recently on some of
the political battles that have been
going on in the social sciences noting
for example that there is very little
political diversity in the views of
social scientists and perhaps even less
on the part of the people in the
humanities and hate recently wrote
something which all all what are you
linked to in the and the description of
this video where he claimed that
universities have to decide between
social justice and truth and on the side
of truth he puts philosopher call named
John Stuart Mill an English philosopher
who said he who knows only his side of
the case knows little of that his
reasons may be good and no one may have
been able to refute them but if he is
equally unable to refute the reasons on
the opposite side if he does not does
not so much as know what they are
he has no ground for preferring either
opinion and then he juxtaposes John
Stuart Mill with Karl Marx who said the
Philosopher's have only interpreted the
world in various ways the point is to
change it
he considers Marx the patron saint of
social justice University which is
oriented around changing the world in
part by overthrowing power structures
and privilege it sees political
diversity as an obstacle to action male
on the other hand according to hate is
the patron saint of what he calls truth
you which sees truth as a process in
which flawed individuals challenge each
other's biased and incomplete reasoning
and in the process all become smarter
hate points out the truth university
dies when it becomes intellectually
uniform or politically Orthodox so I
guess this video is in part my call
along with Jonathan Haidt for young
people to join truth universe
versity but there's a problem with that
because the university is where the
truth is being sought that's the
university but there's a problem and
that is that young people want to change
the world and it's part of what Piaget
the developmental psychologist Piaget
called the messianic stage and there's
some real utility in that because we're
social creatures and as we construct
ourselves and formulate ourselves and
bring our own character into being
predicated on our on our biological
platform our biological being we also
simultaneously have to integrate adjust
to integrate with and negotiate with
society which sometimes needs to be
changed the structure of society has to
be preserved but it has to be updated
and proved as it moves forward and so
part of the problem is how to update and
improve it without doing that so rapidly
that you destroy everything of any value
so the problem I have with the Marxist
perspective and I've had this problem
with it for a long time is that I don't
think that you should trust people whose
primary goal when when when they're
attempting to change the world for the
better is to change other people and you
can tell who those people are because
they're always blaming other people and
they're looking for victims they're
looking for perpetrators and victims and
then they're going off to stop the
perpetrators and I think that's wrong
because as Alexander Solzhenitsyn said
he's a great Russian writer who helped
bring down the Soviet Union he said the
line between good and evil runs down
every every humans heart so that so the
real battle as far as I'm concerned and
I think this goes along with the true
tradition in which John Stuart Mill is
is firmly placed in is that to overcome
tyranny and malevolence and chaos and
nihilism and the desire to bring
everything to a halt you have to repair
the fissures and-and-and the rift that's
in your own soul basically and that
means that you have to confront the the
evil that lives in your own heart and
there's a there's a statement from the
New Testament that I think is very much
apropos with regards to this particular
idea and this is this is part of the
Sermon on the Mount which is a central
text in in Western in the Western
tradition I would say obviously central
to Christianity but central to
everything that Western civilization has
built and so Christ says to his
followers why be holdest thou
the mote that is in thy brother's eye
but considerest not the beam that is in
thine own eye or how wilt thou say to
thy brother let me pull out the mote out
of thine eye and behold a beam is in
thine own eye
thou hypocrite first cast out the beam
out of thine own eye and then shalt thou
see clearly to cast the mote out of thy
brother's eye well I like that quote
because it places the responsibility for
change at every level of being on the
individual and obviously the individual
interacts with society but the idea here
is that unless the individual
straightens out his or her own soul
there's no possibility that the impact
the individual can have on society can
be anything but buts a harmful in
proportion to the harm that's still in
the soul these are important things to
know they're vitally important things to
know so okay so but then we're faced
with the conundrum that young people
also want to change the world but that's
no problem because I think you can bring
you could bring truth University
together with the desire to to make real
change but change change change has to
start at the right place so I'm going to
tell you how I think you should change
yourself so that you can change the
world and so that the world that you
bring into being will be a better world
and all the worst one remember remember
you need to know about this that the
world that the followers of Marx brought
into being in the 20th century killed
more than a hundred million people say
in China and Russia I mean the Soviet
Union and in places like Cambodia and
Vietnam the world certainly changed as a
consequence of Marxist doctrine but it
didn't change in in a good direction and
of course the Marxist doctrine is making
itself heard in a massive way across the
West again now so all right so what
should you do about that well here's an
idea
the first thing you have to do is orient
yourself now you probably have all
watched Pinocchio and Pinocchio is about
how a marionette someone who's whose
strings are being pulled by forces
beyond his comprehension that's the
situation of the undeveloped individual
Geppetto who's a benevolent father so a
benevolent symbol a symbol of benevolent
culture makes a puppet his son and then
wishes on a star now a star is something
that glitters up in the sky and it's and
it's associated with the transcendent
and
beyond and the divine and you know if
you look up in the night sky and it's
very dark you get a feeling of awe it's
because you're confronting your soul so
to speak your individual soul is
confronting the cosmos and you can feel
a relationship between you and and and
and the totality so looking up into the
sky is like a religious experience if
it's a starry sky and to wish upon a
star is to find in a light that Orient's
you like the North Star and to pick a
highest goal to pick the highest goal
you can conceive of and so that's what
Geppetto does he raises his eyes above
his his day-to-day concerns and tries to
establish a relationship with the
highest of all possible values and and
and he has the most profound of wishes
and the most profound of wishes is that
the puppet that he's created could
become a genuine individual genuinely
fully fully developed human being and
that's what you can wish for yourself
that's you can wish and and and and aim
for that in yourself and then you see
that's how you deal with the suffering
that's attendant on life because life is
suffering and because life is very hard
and people get sick and they become
mentally ill and and and there's
malevolence in the world and there's
tragedy and so life is very very hard
and if you're not properly oriented with
regards to life the fact that it's hard
and the fact that it's full of suffering
can can warp and twist and bend you
until you become murderous and resentful
and and even go beyond murderous and
resentment to wish for for genocide and
evil even to wish for the destruction of
everything and so you have to learn how
to strengthen yourself as an individual
so that you can bear the burden of being
without becoming corrupt you have to
decide that that is what you're aiming
for is that you want to become a fully
developed human being and stop being a
pathetic marionette whose strings are
being pulled by horrible forces behind
the scenes so I would say to wish on a
stars to aim at the highest good in the
question then is well what what is the
good well we can answer that in two ways
we could say that the good is the
opposite of evil and I can tell you what
evil is evil is the conscious desire to
produce suffering where suffering is not
necessary and so if you read about what
happened in the Nazi concentration camps
for example or in the in the Russian
concentration camps during the Soviet
time of the Soviet Union you'll get a
good flow
favor for what constitutes evil and evil
is the desire to exploit the
vulnerability of other people to
self-consciously exploit the
vulnerability of other people and to
elevate their suffering beyond their or
anyone's ability to tolerate and so the
good is the opposite of that whatever
the opposite of that is the good is
harder to get a handle on but here's one
hint and I got this from reading Jean
Piaget partly who's a developmental
psychologist and Piaget talked about the
equilibrated state and in equilibrated
state is like a game the children play
where every child wants to play the game
you have a little social group and
that's the children's play group and any
of us the individuals within it those
are the individual children and the
structure is the game and it's a good
game if everyone wants to play it and
and Piaget noted that a game like that
will outperform a game that people have
to be terrorized to play because it
doesn't entail it doesn't require any
enforcement cost and so I've sort of
developed the idea of nil equilibrated
state to think that if if you're aiming
at the good then you want what's good
for you
and I mean good for you as if you were
taking care of yourself and we're good
to yourself we were treating yourself
like someone you loved that was good for
you in a way that would also be good for
your family and then it would be good
for you and your family in a way that
was also good for society and then it
would be good for you and your family
and society in a way that would be good
for the world and then it would be good
now and it would be good next week and
the week after and a year from now and
is long into the future as you can see
so the good is something that's
equilibrate across multiple levels of
being in multiple time frames
simultaneously and it isn't necessarily
that you know what that is going to be
at any given moment but you can orient
yourself so that's the state that you
want to exist in and I can tell you as
far as I can tell when you exist in that
state even moment by moment your life is
imbued with a sense of meaning and that
sense of meaning can help you transcend
suffering the philosopher Nietzsche said
he who has a why can bear anyhow he who
has a why can bear anyhow and so
Nietzsche's idea was that if there was
purpose in your life of sufficient
grandeur that not only could the
suffering in life be a
but maybe it even be appreciated like it
could be that you're willing to bear the
burden of being because of the exciting
things that you can do with being the
things you can build and the things that
you can bring about and that might be
the highest imaginable state of being
and that's that's a form of paradise but
it's not a paradise that you attain by
transforming others it's a paradise that
you attain by transforming yourself and
that's a very difficult thing to do and
it's a very frightening thing to do
because it means that you're you're
retooling your soul and that's that's a
job for a real that's the job for a
forthright and honorable person and it's
an exciting enough task so that it will
keep you occupied for the rest of your
life and then magical things will happen
to you well your while you're doing it
and the world will arrange itself around
you in the most wonderful way in a
musical way so that every part of what
you're experiencing plays off against
every other part in a manner that has
meaning embedded in every aspect of it
and you experience that by the way you
experience that when you listen to a
piece of music that you love music
represents that and that's why people
it's why music nourishes the soul why
it's the highest form of art at least in
my opinion so you have to live your life
as if being is a symphony and you're
playing you're playing your instrumental
part
[Music]
[Applause]
once you are it yourself then you have
an obligation I would say an obligation
to the development of your soul to speak
the truth you have to be oriented
properly though because the truth is is
something that exists in service to an
ideal an ideal of sorts then you can
imagine that you could use your language
two ways you can use your language to
manipulate the world and to extract from
it what you want so for example maybe
you go out on a date with someone and
you decide that the end goal of the date
is to have a sexual partner for the
night and then you can craft your
language to manipulate the person into
providing you with you with what you
want and that's like an instrumental use
of language but the problem with that
there's many problems with that but one
of them is is that what if your idea
about what you should want is wrong like
maybe that's not the way to treat
someone that you're on a date with out
on a date with maybe maybe you're
minimizing and reducing the interactions
between you from what could be a healthy
and elevated state of interaction and
discourse to something that's that
basically the pursuit of impulsive
pleasure and not maybe that's not good
for you next week and the week after and
a month down the road maybe orienting
yourself towards impulsive pleasure is a
very bad idea remember what happens in
Pinocchio Pinocchio goes to Pleasure
Island and Pleasure Island is a place
where impulsive pleasures can be had at
a moment's notice but what Pinocchio
discovers along with Jiminy Cricket that
Pleasure Island is run by masked
totalitarians there they're all dressed
in black you remember they're there
turning the children and adolescents who
are on Pleasure Island
they're depriving about their voice
turning them into brain jackasses and
preparing to sell them as slaves to the
salt mines and so there's an implication
in that story that the pursuit of
impulse of pleasure is one route to
totalitarianism and slavery and I
believe that so perhaps orienting your
language towards the gathering of the
impulsive pleasure is a miss is a misuse
of your highest gift you're the gift of
logos the gift of communication the
alternative is to orient yourself
towards the highest good as we already
described and then speak the truth which
and you can you can tell when you're
doing that because or you can tell when
you're not doing that because if you're
if you're not telling the truth if
you're using someone else's words you're
being
elated into sense by forces that are
behind the scenes you're not using your
own words you're the puppet of an
ideology or another thinker or your own
impulsive desires and you can tell when
you're speaking like that because it
makes you feel weak it makes you feel
weak and ashamed and you can localize
that feeling physiologically if you
listen to yourself talk you can tell
when when you're speaking properly you
will experience a feeling of integration
and strength and when you're speaking in
a deceitful or manipulative manner
you'll feel that you're starting to come
apart at the seams
and what you need to do is practice only
saying things that make you feel
stronger and that'll mean to begin with
it you'll notice that almost everything
you say is a lie it's either a lie or
someone else's words it's very hard to
find your old words but you don't
actually exist until you have your own
words so okay so then you you try to
teach yourself how to speak your own
truth and you listen to other people
while you're doing that because they can
help you shape and correct your words
they'll react to them badly if you
formulate your ideas badly and if you
listen and pay attention then you can
learn to formulate your words more and
more clearly and accurately and that
makes you more and more powerful it
makes you it gives you more and more
authority which is the which is the
beneficial form of power okay so you do
that and then you have to make a
decision of faith and that's basically
well that you can either either use your
language to manipulate the world and
make it do what you want or you can use
your language to try to articulate the
truth as carefully as you possibly can
and then you can see what happens you
have to let go of your desire for the
for the consequences that you want you
have to assume that if you speak the
truth the results are the best that is
possible under the circumstances and so
it's a it's a it's an exciting way of
living in some sense some sense it's
like continually walking off a cliff
because you don't know what's going to
happen next if all you do is say what
you think you know and maybe you're at
work and you say what you think and you
get fired you think oh my god that's a
terrible catastrophe but maybe it's not
because maybe if you're working
somewhere and you have to lie to
maintain your job maybe you shouldn't be
there maybe it's deadening your soul and
damaging you in some permanent manner
and making you corrupt and so you have
to orient yourself you have to speak the
truth
as carefully as you can you have to
listen to others so that you correct
your speech and then you have to allow
the consequences that ensue to unfold as
they will that's the ultimate act of
faith I would say and that's what you do
if you belong to truth University all
right so more practically speaking then
you should educate yourself and it's not
that easy to do now because you have to
find people who can actually tell you
mostly what to read and maybe also how
to write because writing is a way of
formulating your thoughts ever more
precisely that's why you go to
university to learn how to write if you
learn if you know how to write you can
think if you can think and speak and
communicate in writing you're you're
unbelievably powerful in the authority
manner because arguments move the world
forward and if your arguments are tight
and well-constructed and lucid and well
edited and carefully thought through and
you have five rationales for everything
that you're doing which is what happens
if you learn to write properly then
you're like a force of nature man no one
can take you down and that's one of the
things that people aren't taught about
why you go get educated especially in
the humanities humanities education if
it's real organizes your psyche grounds
you puts you on a rock and makes you a
force to contend with but you have to
read the right people and so and those
are the great they're the great people
of the past in my list they're the great
men of the past and that's just how it
is
and so here's who I would recommend I
put reading lists up at Jordan B
Peterson com there's two of them and the
people that I recommend primarily are
their books written by the followed list
of people Fyodor Dostoyevsky Leo Tolstoy
who I think perhaps the greatest
novelists the world has ever seen
Alexander Solzhenitsyn another great
Russian novelist I don't know what it is
about the Russians but man they produce
they produce writers that are
incomparable Alexander Solzhenitsyn
wrote a book called The Gulag
Archipelago
where he analyzed the Soviet prison camp
system that arose after the Leninist
Revolution in the second decade of the
20th century and details an absolutely
precisely how the tenets of Marxism the
Marxist tenants that are supposed to
free everyone and change the world
produce legislation that was that was
absolutely murderous in its consequences
and Solzhenitsyn
painstakingly traces the logical pathway
from the original Marxist principles to
the legislation to the to the genocides
because you'll hear people who are
basically Marxist to say things like
well true Marxism never existed and
Solzhenitsyn took that bad argument
apart in the in the mid-70s and and the
Gulag Archipelago was an intellectual
bomb it it it demolished any credibility
that Marxism had to intellectual
respectability you have to read the book
the book is about the central issue in
our culture at the moment if you don't
read it you're not informed you can't
participate in the debate except as a
puppet and so I wouldn't recommend
participating in this debate as a puppet
because you don't know who's behind the
scenes pulling the strings if you
remember the Pinocchio story the forces
that we're pulling the strings were not
they were not forces that were acting in
Pinocchio's best interest that's for
sure
George Orwell English essayist
incomparable commentator on socialist
totalitarianism even though he was a
left winger and a brilliant one Aldous
Huxley wrote brave new world had some
very brilliant things to say about the
potential demolition of sexual choice of
choice of sexual partner as a part of
part of a you dystopian future Friedrich
Nietzsche a philosopher who described
himself as as someone who thought with a
hammer and Nietzsche is a very very
dangerous person and an absolutely
brilliant writer and Carl Jung who was a
student of Nietzsche and who Nietzsche
was the philosopher who announced the
death of God back in the late 1800s and
Jung spent his whole life attempting to
revivify God that's one way of thinking
about it and so if you or educate
yourself and this is a really good place
to start if you read these authors then
you'll know what else to read if you
read these authors it'll it'll take you
a good long time and it will be very
very hard on you and and you won't be
the same person when you come out and
that's very frightening and because
being torn down and rebuilt his note is
no joke but it beats the hell out of the
alternative which is just to stagnate
and stay as stagnant infant which is
which is not something I recommend
there's nothing uglier than a stagnant
40 year old infant so that's equivalent
just so you know - Pinocchio back to the
Pinocchio story rescuing Geppetto from
the underworld remember
and he was he had kind of turned into a
half jackass after being at the pleasure
island where he was enticed by the way
from a couple of people who that was the
Fox and the cat who attempted to entice
himself into believing that he was a
victim and needed a vacation so
Pinocchio was enticed onto Pleasure
Island by two two figures that played on
his sense of victimization and neuroses
and suffering to convince him that he
didn't have to he didn't have to take
any responsibility for his own existence
and he could just busy himself with
impulsive pleasures right that's how he
fell into the hands of the totalitarian
so on Pleasure Island
anyways Pinocchio after he left Pleasure
Island had to go into the ocean twice
and the second time he went into the
ocean he was looking for his father well
everyone's father from a mythological
perspective is dying in the underworld
in the chaos because everyone inhabits a
culture that's that's sick and old so to
speak and it's sick and old because it
was made by the dead and the living have
to revivify it continually in order for
it to be a dynamic force and the living
have to revivify their connection with
the culture internally to because you're
constructions of culture although not
only constructions of culture and you
have to understand history because
otherwise you can't understand yourself
you're a historical creature and so you
have to rescue your dead father from the
belly of the beast from the dragon
guests remember the whale in Pinocchio
is also a fire-breathing dragon and that
means you have to face the thing that
you most fear and when you do that
you'll rescue your father from the
underworld these are very complex ideas
and you can read about them in my book
maps of meaning if you want it's on the
reading list I put a free copy of it on
Jordan B Peterson com so you can
download it I take apart these sorts of
things in detail so anyways you have to
revivify your father before you can
become real and that's part of the
problem with the the feminists in
feminist and social justice warrior
insistence on the existence of the
patriarchy it's like everyone's known
since the beginning of time that culture
is corrupt and tyrannical but it's also
protective and benevolent even the
language used is a product of culture
and so you don't overthrow the
patriarchy Yuri vivify your culture and
you do that by adopting responsibility
for your own being and then acting as a
moral agent in the culture that's what
you do
to become educated so read these books
read these books they'll change your
life I guarantee it they'll change your
life they'll take you apart
they'll devastate you and then they'll
rebuild you into something far greater
than you are now
you're hurt don't worry Jenny you need
to get yourself out
follow the chamber and you'll find wrong
you
you were brilliant folks I just wasn't
quick enough
[Music]
of course Phoenix tears have healing
powers thanks
it's alright today and that's what to
aim for so then and here's something
that will help you my colleagues and I
have developed a series of online
writing programs called the self
authoring suite and they help people
write about their past and organize that
and their present personality and
organize and understand that and then
the future and the future authoring
program asks you to write about six
different dimensions of your life so it
asks you first of all treat yourself as
if you're someone that you want to help
and lend that someone that you love and
take care of and someone that you want
to help and then it asks you well if you
could if you could organize your life in
the best possible manner and in keeping
with those principles we discussed
earlier um what do you want what do you
want for your career like what do you
want what would make your life
meaningful what do you want for your
career
what do you want for your family and
from your family what do you want for an
intimate relationship how are you going
to handle how are you going to take care
of your mental and physical health how
are you going to handle drug drug and
alcohol use it asks you a series of
fundamental questions like that to get
your mind moving and then it asks you to
write for 15 minutes about what your
life could be like fifty three to five
years in the future if it was laid out
like you were laying out a life for
someone you deeply cared about and so
you're asked to write for 15 minutes
about that without worrying too much
about structure the structure of the
argument or any grammatical niceties
that that's put off for later so that
gives you a little heaven dame for right
it's like well if I could have this my
life would be clearly worthwhile even if
I had to put up with a fair bit of
suffering along the way that's what
you're trying to construct and you can
think about that as a heaven worth
moving towards and then the second part
of the program asks you to write about
what your life would be like three to
five years down the road if all of your
bad habits and nihilistic tendencies and
proclivity towards resentment and lack
of desire to shoulder responsibility if
all your weak points got the upper hand
and just ordered you into the ground and
everyone knows that you know what you'd
be like if you just let everything slide
and and you know what particular hell
you were ended up heading towards and so
the set the second part of the program
asks you to write about what your life
would be like three to five years down
the road if everything just went to hell
around you and so that gives you a hell
to avoid and heaven to strive for
you need both of those because that's
what keeps you properly motivated in
life and then the second half of the
program that the next part of the
program helps you turn your vision of
the desirable future into an
implementable reality and to articulate
it fully and to articulate the arguments
for why you want that and those even
help you overcome your own doubts right
it's not only to argue against other
people it's to argue against the
chattering demons of nihilism and
hopelessness and ideological possession
that that exists in your mind and in
society simultaneously you need powerful
weapons to fight back against those so
here's an offer for you we've made the
future authoring program available free
for the next while I don't know how long
a while be but let's assume a week or
something like that
and so if you go to wwl farthing com
slash future authoring dot HTML you can
read about the program there and now I
got to tell you we've used this program
on about 5,000 University students so
far mostly in Holland but some in Canada
as well and what we've shown is that
they the program if you if you complete
this program even if you do it badly and
I would recommend it do it badly man it
doesn't matter you don't have to do it
perfectly do it badly and then maybe do
it better as you move forward but at
least do it badly it increases the
performance of university students it
increases their grades by between 20 and
25 percent and decreases their dropout
by about the same percent and so we have
doubt on 5,000 people one of those
papers has been published and I'll put
that in in the description in the
description of this video and so this
program really works if you do it and
and so I would highly recommend that you
do it anyways
you can read about the program there
click purchase for 1495 then enter this
code change yourself that'll give you a
1495 discount and that means you can
have the program for free and so here's
what Millennials should do if they want
to change the world the first thing they
should do is orient themselves to the
good and that's away from evil away from
malevolence away from the manufacture of
pointless suffering and pain away from
Auschwitz let's say and away from the
Gulag Archipelago
and the terrible Soviet camps and the
massive
murders that occurred in China you want
to get it end you want to get as far
away from that as you possibly can
whatever direction is away from that is
a good direction and and then you also
want to contemplate what the highest
possible good could look like for you
and your family and your society we
already discussed that and then you need
to speak the truth in relationship to
that and then you need to educate
yourself and then you need to shoulder
your responsibility responsibility is a
good thing because it makes you strong
to bear up under it makes you strong you
can turn yourself into a you can free
yourself from your strings and turn
yourself into a genuine individual and
then you can shoulder the world and then
you're in a position to make to make
change as a person like that your mere
being will change the world in a
positive direction and that's what you
should be aiming for so read the books
that I put up on my site and do the
future authoring program and that will
improve your life dramatically and
that's how you can change the world